face à simone veil lionel jospin qui
conduit lui la liste socialiste pour les
européennes le numéro un du ps a choisi
de faire une campagne sur le terrain en
assistance sur l'explication des
problèmes qui se posent aujourd'hui à la
france dans le cadre du marché commun
dominique laurie nous présente
lionel jospin qu'il ait subi lors de
l'un de ses rares moments de loisirs de
suite le reportage de dominique laurie
permettez je vous donne une indication
en avril 80 aux dossiers de l'écran au
cours du débat sur le congrès de tours
les français georges marchais le premier
découvre un lieutenant combatif de
françois mitterrand
c'est sans doute une date dans la
carrière de lionel jospin ce qui n'est
pas votre cas depuis cet énarque de 46
ans profession d'économie a fait son
chemin
secrétaire national puis premier
secrétaire du ps après la victoire de la
gauche
lionel jospin est aujourd'hui l'un des
hommes charnière du pouvoir le lien en
quelque sorte entre l'appareil d'état et
le parti socialiste représenté
côté vivant du parti et dans la société
dans
je suis en contact avec la réalité qu
étant même si je ne suis pas dans l'état
s'est passé
damman la charnière c'est un lieu
décisif en même temps c'est là où les
tensions sont les plus forts toujours
peut-être
le mague la santé et c'est un bûcheur
c'est sans doute pour ces raisons que
françois mitterrand en a fait son
successeur à la tête du parti socialiste
depuis il a imposé un style un style
rigoureux dit ses amis quelque peu
austère ajoute ses détracteurs tout cela
c'est l'image politique mais il ya un
autre personnage celui qu'on rencontre
loin des tribunes politiques
un dimanche et les amis à la campagne
c'est la détente
là il est plus accessible le plus et le
plus extraordinaire c'est le racing ne
pensait pas vous vous livrez pas
beaucoup on est toujours que vous êtes
sur votre réserve c'est une attitude
nécessaire pour l'homme politique ou
plutôt un comportement normal je pense
que oui face au monde extérieur il ya
une forme de pudeur je pense que je n'ai
pas beaucoup envie de livrer de ma vie
familiale
bien que
marie veut maintenant de le faire un peu
et puis je vais tellement d'impudeur
parfois tellement de personnages composé
dans la politique je me console d'être
comme ça oui mais certains disent que
pardonnez moi mais vous n'êtes pas un
arbre et pourtant je trouve que je suis
assez marrant corps il vous arrive de
douter un jour dans une réunion j'ai je
répondais à tous
j'avais réponse à tout comme on dit mais
quelqu'un m'a dit plutôt quelqu'un de
sympathisants a dit je n'ose pas vous
doutez jamais et je me suis dit que
cette idée je la garderai en tête
toujours
disons que c'est ma seule façon de vous
répondre quand même une parenthèse vide
refermer d'une campagne l'autre loeb
redevient militants car pour l'heure il
s'agit de défendre avec acharnement des
convictions politiques